hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
symbiosis symbiosis is a close long-term
association between two different
species and it actually turns out that
symbiosis plays a critical role in the
survival of many different species and
also through what is now today known as
the endosymbiotic theory symbiosis plays
a huge role in how you carry on it cells
developed through the course of
evolution from symbiosis of prokaryotic
cells if you are interested in learning
more about the endosymbiotic theory then
please see my video on that topic but
now let's talk about symbiosis in
particular first a close long-term
association what do we mean by that well
it means that two different species
either closely associate and interact
sometimes this means that one species
even lives on or inside another species
and they do so long-term this means
either throughout the entire lifespan of
those species or perhaps only during
specific stages of the lifespan or
sometimes it means that they're not
always associated with each other but
they're frequently found together for a
variety of reasons and we're going to
see examples of those types as we go
along now there are three different ways
that symbiosis can be categorized and
we're going to talk about each one of
those first let's start with the type of
symbiosis where both species benefit
this is called mutualism
so in mutualism the two species that are
closely interacting or associated
they're both benefiting from that
association for example if we look at
humans and gut bacteria all humans have
bacterial symbionts that live inside
their gastrointestinal tract
these bacteria benefit because they gain
a place to live inside their human host
and they also gain nutrients from what
their human hosts eat humans
likewise benefit because these gut
bacteria help them to digest their food
releasing extra nutrients some gut
bacteria even produce vitamins that the
human hosts can then use and the gut
bacteria can also fill this niche so
that pathogenic bacteria are less likely
to be able to take hold another example
of mutualism is the spider crab and
algae algae will grow on the spider crab
hosts that means the algae gain a place
to live the spider crab in turn benefits
because this is a type of camouflage
it's able to blend in better with the
ocean floor so that it blends into its
environment and is therefore less likely
to be recognized by potential predators
so those are examples of mutualism where
both of the species benefit another type
of symbiosis is where one species
benefits while the other is not affected
that is the second species and the
Association is neither helped nor harmed
this is called commensalism
an example of commensalism is remoras
which are a type of fish and sharks the
remoras will actually attach to sharks
and thus gain a way of locomotion so a
way of movement or transport the Sharks
on the other hand are not affected by
the presence of the remoras another
example of commensalism is clownfish and
sea anemones the clownfish are the ones
that benefit here like the remoras in
the previous example the clownfish will
live in a close association with the sea
and enemies meaning they actually can
live sort of inside among the tentacles
of the sea anemones and this gives them
a place to live and a way to protect
themselves from predators that would
otherwise be able to attack them now
let's talk about the third type of
symbiosis and this is actually when one
organism directly harms the other
meaning that one organism the one that's
doing the harming benefits in some way
and the association is detrimental to
the other species the one that is harmed
this type of symbiosis is called
parasitism and there are many examples
of parasitism that i'm sure you're
familiar with this includes a variety of
pathogens bacterial pathogens viral
pathogens fungal pathogens that will
invade a host and cause disease during
their replication and as they steal
various nutrients from the host or kill
host cells or work in a variety of other
ways that harms the host there are also
various types of parasites I'm sure
you're familiar with things like
tapeworms fleas ticks that live either
on or in a host and are detrimental to
that host
so both pathogen
and parasites are symbiotic organisms
that live in this close association with
a host organism but the host organism in
this case is harmed so these are the
three types of symbiosis I hope that
this video has helped you to understand
that differences in these three types
and thanks for watching biology
professor